yeah I came to this video playing DD
from France I think isn't he an FM or
something hmm didn't seem to be the case
I thought he was all right so it's um
probably Kings Indian coming on no no
goons out let's play this fat eh for
line I don't know a good line anyway I
mean no acid really knowing not only
having a vague idea hmm five interesting
yeah no idea it's a completely
unexplored territory yeah this is really
weird chest but interesting let's see
Bishop g4 them I don't think how to how
to play this it's a really interesting
age 67 h6 would actually sent the bishop
back to f8 hmm not sure that this is
such an accomplishment but something to
consider i take i don't think i've
gained much they're probably i need to
do that
trying to use the extraordinary features
of the position let's put it that way
okay just retreating hmm yeah I probably
nicho need to go back but this is in
fact interesting it's an interesting
position ready and I quite like it
actually are you six I can play six
until I guess I should I should take
this chance ah the doorbell
alright so let's see this game probably
d 5v5 looks very very dangerous or has a
40 yeah it's probably quite good for
light but not at all easy to play hmm
yeah multiforme as the is the idea I
should I take first hmm they can take
with the Queen um and what to now take
is just take here baby chicks now this
doesn't really hard I can check once you
form take on see form it takes what the
pole I can take Bishop takes a form we
call of Queen a 4 at the end yeah with
the crazy position but that's what you
get for playing edge form ok hmm I don't
want to go Bishop f4 i Ken that she's
attacking you six phone
can also force check in yeah maybe this
is good to check justice check and then
Queenie to covering e6 and then I'm
going Bishop f4 next move yeah why not
just covering your six and preparing
Bishop f4 I mean the porn on H 636
completely completely am freezes
position 96 young okay threatening on d4
okay I need to take and still be sure I
from attending book see one it still
should be should be quite nice yeah I
don't really seem of rooks you want
maybe rook c8 intending to sack the
Queen so looks the hydroxy one Quincy
one looks a bishop c1 Roxy one King dito
yeah but it should be winning actually
with all these dead pieces in the corner
yeah so Roxy one
this is something better they are
probably not no we didn't sacrifice I
didn't think this was possible okay so
can take it and now queen bee fire film
I know this is hanging sorry cautions so
okay let's go a4 a5 dislodging this this
night on b6 irie cannot believe you that
you can play without the bishop and the
rook a5 takes on f4 takes on yeah this
should be winning I mean really
I said something better this chap should
be enough Luke here time morning oh my
time I completely forgot about the time
this is chris is this is bad
down to 12 seconds what deck check check
Queen B 7 9 27 I hope it's a maid
anything else then I made is not enough
simply because of the time check check
check
Quincy admit checkmate Wow five seconds
left okay this was a really weird game
maybe you can check it out for yourself
because I have a friend over here I
don't want to do a long analysis but it
was quite funny thanks for watching